In this "Android
Tool Time" pro tip,
I'm going to show you
some Android Studio expert
tips to keep you in the zone
and increase your productivity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You're probably already
familiar with some
of the most common
shortcuts-- turning
on automatic importing of
unambiguous class names,
pressing Shift twice
to search everywhere,
or using Shift-F6 to rename
a variable, method, or class.
So we'll skip past those and
try something a little more
nuanced than that.
Here, I need to change
the duplicated method
to set latitude.
I can bring up Auto
Complete to make life easy
with Control-Space.
But when I select
the right method,
it annoyingly inserts a new
method in front of the old one.
Unless I hit Tab
instead, in which case,
it'll replace the old
method with the new one.
Similarly, if I hit
Control-Shift-Space,
I get only suggestions
of the expected type.
And after I make the
selection, hitting Tab
will replace the old value.
For both Control-Space
and Control-Shift-Space,
hitting the shortcut
a second time
will suggest auto
completion options
based on chained expressions,
collections, lists, and arrays.
You already know how to navigate
your code using the cursor keys
and using Alt-Left and
Right to skip across words
and holding Shift
to select them.
But did you know
you can use Alt-Up
to extend your selection
to the next containing
node and Alt-Down to
correspondingly shrink
your selection?
Once selected, use Alt-Shift
Up or Down to move the code.
Use postfix code completion
to transform an already typed
expression into another
one, such as creating
a full loop over a list
or turning an expression
into an if statement.
You can use Command-J to see all
the valid postfixes for a given
context.
For more complex
patterns, use live
templates to insert
templated code snippets.
For example, using
a toast shortcut
makes it easy to add an
new toast where only need
to specify the text to display.
There are dozens of
generic and Android
specific live
templates, including
a selection of
logging shortcuts,
including log M that
inserts the current method
name and the name and value of
each parameter passed into it.
Easier log statements
are great for debugging,
but did you know
you can also set
conditional breakpoints that can
log the output of expressions?
It's also possible
to define a custom
rendering for objects while
you're evaluating expressions
rather than relying on
their two-string values.
There are so many handy
features in Android Studio
that it's easy to forget
all those shortcuts.
Luckily, you just
need to remember
one-- Command-Shift-A--
and start typing
keywords to find them.
For example, the
Structural Search feature
lets you search
for code patterns
without resorting to
regular expressions.
If you enable Structural Search
Inspection and borrow a mouse,
you can even provide warnings
around methods and syntax
that you wish to discourage
within your code.
Similarly, you can use the
Structural Replace feature
to find and replace deprecated
code or common anti-patterns.
And use Structural
Search Inspection here
to offer a replacement
snippet as a quick fix option.
There are hundreds
of tips and tricks
to make your Android
Studio experience faster,
more productive, and
mostly mouse-free.
Subscribe to Android
Developers on YouTube
and tune into "Android Tool
Time" for more Android tool
time pro tips.